the way we'll proceed is as follows
first I'll just give extremely brief
introductions to all the members of the
panel then the panel members in turn
will unburden themselves of whatever
they feel like saying about the P versus
NP problem and related questions we'll
spend about 20 to 25 minutes on wisdom
from the panel and then I will turn to
questions raised by the audience and ask
the panelists to to respond to those
questions the first panelist to speak
will be christos papadimitriou and I'm
going to be merciless in holding every
panelist to a three-minute limit
you said 20 to 25 for you so
computationally something are extremely
practical in the worldly so it must be
interesting for that okay and frankly I
don't think so okay you know I the
reason why this is an interesting
question I think is much more basic
there are some questions that you cannot
you cannot dare not call important I
mean know about the is there a single
equation for that governs the cosmos is
there what was the origin of how did
life begin on earth okay so you know if
you want to argue that these questions
are not important I don't want work with
you okay so and I believe that that P
versus NP is you know is can exhaustive
search always be telescoped okay how can
you not try to answer this how to hand
you not want to answer no the answer to
this question you know if if we managed
to live on this planet for enough for a
couple of thousand years more I mean oh
I don't know we are not able to answer
this question I mean Oh what what we we
know what's the point okay
so the other thing you know is what is
it what does the MPP were champion
np-completeness means in practice okay
because many of you may know that that
there are price there are practitioners
who come and tell me and tell everybody
all of us you know these MP complete
problems I solve them you know thousands
of them every every day so you know my
company depends on it okay so as I saw
them so you see people are very clever
very innovative very versatile and
essentially they can live with anything
including a P completeness ok you know
so so they they they find ways around
around even the extremely hard problems
all right let me know that so you know
the point is the following
but when a problem has been proven
np-complete it's not like it will never
be solved it will be solved okay but you
have to change what solution means in
order to solve it okay you know you the
solution cannot be clean cannot be
satisfying
okay cannot be you know when you when
you actually prove a problem to be in P
when you develop a polynomial time
algorithm for a problem that's really
amazing okay you know so you you really
have done a good day's work right I know
there was this man called Jack Edmonds
who is his time in the 60s he found this
amazing algorithms for some very very
complicated problems okay polynomial
time algorithms I know for a fact that
he was very satisfied that day okay no I
know I know I you know he slept very
well that night sure so ultimately P
versus NP then is about peace of mind
and a good night's sleep okay
okay idag lected to introduce Christos
Christos is a long-term colleague at
University of California Berkeley and a
Princeton PhD from 1976 our next speaker
is OMA Rheingold who is at the Mountain
View Laboratory of Microsoft and
received his PhD from the Weitzman
Institute in Israel before I start just
one sentence to complete Christos and
even if we don't solve
a great problem is one that even if we
don't solve it we get so much on the way
and I think this is true for all the
other problems Chris was mentioned and I
think it's also true for for P versus NP
and we didn't only spend decades there
not solving it and but I want to claim
now that if I'm taking a physical kind
of an analogue when you want to learn
about computational hardness
computations and what's hard
we need to view it in all ranges so from
the stars and the galaxies on the way to
the atoms in the particles and and the
questions kind of down there is how does
hardness form how does it how those
things become hard and are there any
anything in the range between things
that we cannot solve and things that are
very easy and I'll try to give very
quick examples for that the first one is
something called a pricing via
processing an idea from 22 years ago for
fighting spam which I think can be found
this way to things like Bitcoin and this
is the point of what was the issue with
spam spam is very effective because
emails are very cheap so if you send
your email to 1 million people and only
one of them answer to your Nigerian scam
this is still worthwhile
so perhaps an approach is to make email
a little bit more expensive
and here is an idea whenever I want to
send somebody an email I left two in
return so a very simple problem for
example one Sudoku problem which turns
out to be also np-complete and now when
I solve it with my email I'm going to
send the solution to the problem but now
to use such an idea we will in need to
understand the problem so we know that
when Sudoku problems become very very
large during feasible it's very hard to
solve we cannot solve them and where
there are very small children can solve
them so working in between is the soft
spot for that we need a very fine
understanding and one other thing that I
don't know how can I do with the mic so
when we have a a card we know that every
time we play with them we need to
somehow shuffle them and we know that
doing it once is not good enough right
it still has a lot of structure but if
we do it I don't know seven times eight
times it's already good enough and we
can know it also for various other
things very simpler kind of shuffles so
we know exactly how many times we need
to do it to create something to create
something let's say let's random enough
very similar ideas are useful in
cryptography and there it's not about
turning things into something very
random but turning it to something hard
that can hide your messages and finally
exactly so in the information theoretic
sense in the randomness sense it's very
easy to know exactly I can tell you
seven is a good number of shuffles
really understanding what's the number
of shuffles that make things from very
easy to very hard is exactly the kind of
problems down downstairs that we want to
answer
Thank You lemon
next speaker is Ryan Williams the
Carnegie Mellon PhD and the professor at
Stanford University
thank you so I want to talk a bit about
professor tipsters remarks on how to
prove P different from NP things like
that so I want to say something which
may be a little controversial but is
true so so very few people to my
knowledge actually work on P versus NP
and among those who do almost all of
them are utter crackpots who have no
idea what they do myself included
neither okay and uh and why is that why
is that well I want to give you a few
remarks as to why one is that we're very
far from understanding problems like P
versus NP understanding what can be done
feasibly with computers and what cannot
be done you saw this very large Venn
diagram professor sips are so much of
that Venn diagram could completely
collapse as for Serena like you could
have exponential time computations be
solvable with in polynomial randomized
time so that our p class and primality
was then could solve everything in
exponential time like so this thing
could totally collapse or we think it's
proper we think that there's a very nice
Venn diagram to layout but but we're
really really far understand that so to
refer again to Professor sisters talk we
have to like really whacking on that
computer to actually prove it can't
solve NP problems we have to like break
its legs its arms its neck and you know
we have to do some damage yeah so like
for example you could try to show that
algorithms with very restricted memory
extremely restricted memory like so
small they can't even store a partial
solution at all to show that they cannot
solve NP problems like leak this is
completely open oven formally this is
called the log space for his NP question
but but just so there are always other
question
that we still have no idea how to
approach really we don't know step one
and and we we actually kind of know why
we don't know okay so there are these
soap lose these no-go theorems are
so-called barriers as they're called
it's basically state the common proof
techniques that we know like some of the
lot of techniques and recursion theory
and so on are just simply not strong
enough to distinguish between things
like P and NP or even much much weaker
questions than P versus NP and so not
only can we not prove it we can prove
that we cannot prove it right so this is
like a lot of pessimism and complexity
theory but actually I am an optimist
okay despite all that stuff I am very
much an optimist there are a lot of new
techniques which get around these
barriers in fact they and just at a very
high level what they do is they show a
very abstract way how efficient computer
programs for solving some tasks can be
turned into impossibility results P not
equal NP type results for solving other
tests so so take leveraging sort of
human intuition and problem solving like
abilities we can actually show that
other problems are not solvable
efficiently and so understanding is the
connection cheney's is very important
Thanks oh you don't sound like a
crackpot at all
next we have Russell and Parvati so
Berkley PhD from 1992 and a professor at
UC San Diego um the first thing I want
to do is just respectively disagree with
Christos on one point which is those of
us who have failed to resolve the P
versus NP problem frequently go on to
rich and rewarding lives in other ways
and those who don't may be classified as
crackpots what P versus NP is a really
fundamental problem as all of my
colleagues have stress why want to go go
on to mention is that it's actually not
sort of the ultimate end of complexity
theory it's really the first step of
complexity theory it's a big step but
it's still the first step one example
where we'd want to go next comes in from
some of the applications of having heart
problems namely to cryptography and
security where you want to have the
hardness the difficulty of solving
search problems prevent hackers from
misusing your system now there are two
distinctions that you need to go beyond
proving that P is different from NP P is
different from NP means that there
exists hard instances of these problems
but it doesn't tell you which instances
are really hard in it of itself it
doesn't tell you how to manufacture hard
instances or how to manufacture
instances of a known difficulty like
Omer was mentioning Hugh he would like
for his spam filter okay so for that to
try to come we have to understand not
just how hard NP problems are in the
worst case but how hard they are on
different ways of manufacturing these
hard problems different probabilistic
distributions
which is the subject of Leven theory of
average-case complexity however that's
even that's not the end because we have
to be able to distinguish between
legitimate users who should be able to
solve our problems and attackers who
shouldn't be able to solve the problems
so what we need to to base security on
hard problems is some notion of not just
computational problem that's hard but
what I like to call a computational
puzzle that's hard the distinction
between a puzzle and a problem is that a
puzzle in a puzzle someone who made who
someone knows the answer in particular
the person who makes up the puzzle the
person who designs the system who picks
the keys knows how to solve the problem
but the attacker the person reading the
puzzle in the paper doesn't have known
how to solve so those two barriers going
from worst case to average-case
complexity and from average-case
complexity to puzzles would remain after
we resolved P versus NP thank you
Russell
sandy irani is going to tell us about
how quantum computing bears on these
issues sandy got her PhD from Berkeley
in 1991 I'm proud to say that you as my
student and she's a professor at UC
Irvine so there's been a lot of interest
and press recently on the prospects of
quantum computation and the idea behind
quantum computation is that the physical
world at the atomic scale is governed by
the laws of quantum mechanics which are
fundamentally different from the
physical laws that govern the
macroscopic world so the hope is that we
can somehow encode information at the
atomic level perhaps in the spin of
electrons or in the energy level of
atoms and manipulate it somehow in order
to harness the dynamics of quantum
mechanics to actually solve
computational problems now we don't know
yet whether we can actually build
quantum computers on a large scale but
the principles of quantum mechanics that
would be used in a quantum computer
have been all borne out experimentally
on a small scale and based on those
principles we've developed a theoretical
model for what a quantum computer would
look like and one of the most celebrated
results in quantum computation is due to
Peter shor and he proved that if we
could build a quantum computer then we
could factor numbers so Mike set me up
perfectly for my spiel because he
explained to you how we believe that
factoring is actually difficult on
classical computers and it's an
extremely important problem for
cryptography so if we can build quantum
computers then we could potentially
crack modern crypto systems and use
commercial use today now it begs the
question then could quantum computers be
used to solve these so-called
np-complete problems can we take it to
the next step and there were a bit more
pessimistic and one of the the
mysterious and beautiful things about
quantum mechanics is it says that matter
actually exists simultaneously in
different states so the natural thing to
do with a quantum computer would be to
use these multiple states to in parallel
explore different possibilities so we
would take the search problem that might
talked about sake leak and each
different state would simultaneously
explore a different possible subset of
the nodes to see if it's a cleek
the problem is is at the end the
measurement so the problem is if you've
been stored your information in the spin
and of electron you can't just peek
inside and see what it what it's doing
you have to perform a measurement and
the result of the measurement not only
changes the system but it gives us very
limited access so it may be the case
that one of these possible States has
discovered a click of a certain size but
if we measure the system it's the the
event that we actually discover the
click has very low probability and so
there's actually a theoretical result
that's a little too complicated to
explain here but it says that the
exploitation of quantum parallelism in
such a naive way isn't going to work so
it basically leaves us in a state that's
very similar to our understanding
of np-completeness on classical
computers the idea is that we basically
have to understand a lot more about the
structure of these problems to know
whether they can be solved on a quantum
or classical computer as it turns out
factoring has more structure and that's
why Peter shor was able to exploit that
structure to use quantum computers but
we don't know whether that structure
exists in this in the other kind of
search problems that are np-complete
okay
now we're going to turn to mathematical
logic Ron Fagan got his PhD from
Berkeley in 1973 in the logic group and
he's an IBM fellow at the IBM Almaden
Research Lab thank you dick
so I believe that every scientists
should spend some least modest amount of
time every year thinking about the very
hardest problems in their field so I in
particular do spend several days at
least every year thinking about the P
versus NP problem I don't know have a
crackpot I mean some people say you
spent 40 years thinking about one
problem he crazy but anyway I do you
think about it and the approach I use as
dick mentioned is logic probably the
result I'm best known for is something
called thaegan's theorem where I showed
that a problem is an NP if it only think
you expressed in a certain language so
using that approach I have several at
least twice proven that P equals NP and
at least twice proven P does not equal
NP and the proof that last is the
longest I had a proof that P does not
equal NP that lasted for three days I
showed it to well I still believe that I
showed it to a famous the irritation who
couldn't find the problem then after I
found the bug just for fun I decided to
run it by some some famous theoreticians
and see if they could find the bug and
two of them one of whom is on today's
panel I'm not going to say who could not
find the bug and it turned out that the
bug was that I had misused Fagin's
theorem
and so I think that's probably why they
couldn't find the bug because they gave
me a pass I mean if anyone knows how do
you apply fake exam it's Fagin so that
part has got to be okay okay oh thank
you run it's only fitting that Mike
should have the last word before that I
just want to pay tribute to a former
Berkeley professor Manuel Blum a great
leader in our field who moved on to
Carnegie Mellon University and who was
the thesis advisor of three members of
our panel one of whom is Mike thanks
dick so I just wanted to follow up a
little bit on the comment of Ryan's
about you know is it possible that the P
versus NP question is just beyond
mathematics could it be that the basic
saxy axioms of mathematics that we've
accepted you know for a century or more
just are not enough to prove P versus NP
one way or the other that situation is
known to occur for some other problems
in mathematics for example some of you
may know that there are different sizes
of infinity out there the infinity
associated with the integers and the
infinity associated with the real
numbers are not the same infinity the
real numbers are actually mean these are
the numbers with all the decimals and as
opposed to just the integers the real
numbers are known to be a bigger
infinity and so a question that rose
very early on in this theory of
infinities is whether there's an
infinity in between the size of the
integers and the size of the reals and
that problem was eventually shown to be
unsolvable using the basic tools of
mathematics
it just doesn't follow from the basics
at basic axioms so maybe that's also
true of P versus NP and some of these
results that Ryan mentioned there are
some
barriers that sort of suggest certain
methods are not going to work I just
want to state for the record I don't
believe that that's true I think that
the P versus NP problem is a problem of
a different character than these
problems about say infinities or these
other kinds of independent problems
because those problems deal with things
that are very far from our ordinary
intuition and P versus NP is something
that's very down-to-earth and I believe
that the axioms do give us enough
strength if we're only smart enough to
answer questions like P versus NP but
you know when these these theorems about
barriers I believe really you know this
is maybe a lawn fair but basically the
amount is showing well the methods that
we know so far are not going to work
well that's true they don't work there's
going to take something you're going to
take some new completely new radically
different idea but just because we've
been around working on this problem for
50 years or whatever you know doesn't
and we haven't solved it doesn't mean
it's unsolvable but just not haven't
been smart enough okay so that's that's
an optimistic note I believe so
I guess now that the was supposed to
take question or a we have questions to
to to it
I haven't I know I have here a certain
number of questions from the audience so
we'll just go through some of the
questions that have arisen from the
audience and I'll right I'll read out
the question and if you feel that you
are the best person to answer it stick
up your hand if the P versus NP problem
were solved tomorrow how would the world
be different
Scott Aaronson who is a professor at MIT
is talked about that very problem and he
the way he describes it if P equals NP
turns out to be true then we're in a
vastly different world than where we are
in today for example cryptography
wouldn't work lots of things wouldn't
work you lose your privacy because Cosby
easily crackable so it'd be a very
different world we'd be living in if P
equals NP and we believe P does not
equal NP we believe that's our world but
we don't know that how would the world
be different if we knew that P was
unequal to NP we'd be much much smarter
no like like the things we would have to
know about polynomial time computational
feasible computation would be so deep
and so vast compared to what we know
about what computers can do there would
be so many other consequences if it's
sort of it would be impossible to prove
P Devin from NP and not prove up like a
bunch of other amazing things about
feasible computation like that that's
how deep the question is a great answer
Thanks
all right here's another one suppose P
equals NP but the degree of the
polynomial for np-complete problems is
prohibitively high maybe it's 42 what's
your reaction well I'm not here 42 is
that big but so say I think I think
people I think maybe this question it's
a very common question it's not a it's a
very good question but it's also maybe a
slightly misguided question because
polynomial versus exponential was sort
of or polynomial versus non polynomial
was sort of our shorthand for
making a quantitative problem exactly
how hard are these search problems into
a qualitative problem and if it turned
out that the actual runtime if I let me
say if I had a lower bound on the time
to solve search problems of n to the
thousand if I knew that search problems
required a huge polynomial amount then I
say in some sense the problem has been
resolved okay if on the other hand I
knew an upper bound an algorithm that
took time into a very slowly growing
function in some sense the problem has
been resolved or a lot of progress has
been made on it even if it didn't
technically answer the P versus NP
problem the sad case is that we're no
know we're not--we're not even close
we don't have a super linear time bound
we're not close to end to the 42
we don't have end to the 40 we don't
have an N squared lower bound okay so
we're not at all close you give me an
end to the 42 lower bound I'll be
ecstatic you give me an end to the login
upper bound I'll be ecstatic so the the
exact polynomial versus non polynomial
is just the easiest way to phrase the
problem it's not really the be-all and
end-all thing we wanted to scream with
me or okay you believe P equals NP y
equals
the permissible answer is no then so I
think maybe we could I think it I don't
think there's any reason to believe P
equals NP but you could be skeptical
that P that you know maybe our belief
that P not equal NP is unfounded
you know so you I I I can see being
agnostic but I can't see being like a
strong believer that P equals NP at this
point I just want to comment that
there's a guy named Mick horse I tie at
IBM is a brilliant theoretician and he
thinks it's quite possible that P equals
NP but that the algorithms for solving
for example the quick problem are so
incredibly complicated I mean so just
full of loops this and that that that no
human being can understand it
no we're incapable analyzing it so it
might be true it's just that we're not
capable with our limited Minds to even
understand it or to prove it what about
other galaxies either universes perhaps
I'm a big into other universes that's
another whole story
okay okay here's another one why is it
that some problems such as pattern
recognition and perception can be solved
faster by people than by machines
um okay
I think the short short answer is you
look at how much time evolution has had
to design good programs for these things
and how much time people have had to
design good programs were these things
we're talking about you know 400 million
years versus 40 years so evolution has a
good head start on us yes Mike you know
interpolating also what Ryan said you
know that not only do we not understand
how to prove things like you know P
different from NP but I think it's
entirely possible that we don't
understand very well the class of
algorithms that there are things that
there are amazing things out there that
the brain does that we don't have a clue
about and it's conceivable that there
are some incredible procedures out there
that we haven't discovered yet because
they're very complicated or they very
deep in some way and perhaps you know
you know it you know understanding the
limits of computation may also help you
understand something about its
capabilities so good thank you
here's one that Edward Snowden could
possibly answer is it possible that the
NSA has solved P equals NP but isn't
telling anyone and
and how would how would we know I don't
know of course it's possible if they
knew they would definitely not tell
anyone but actually Edward Snowden gives
us a big hint because in his revelations
it said that the NSA was putting in trap
doors into weakening encryption
standards and and also you know sort of
badgering tech companies into revealing
passwords if they already knew how to
crack P versus NP they wouldn't have
needed to do those things what's what's
the most remarkable false proof of P
equals NP or P unequal to NP that you've
come across I don't know if I'd call it
remarkable but there was very very
highly publicized attempted proof of P
does not equal NP that a few years ago
by D law car at HP Labs and the one of
the interesting things is the entire a
huge amount of mathematical community
including fields medalists and so on
jumped on to it and analyze it I mean
this is the worst possible set of
referees if your insurer nightmare set
of referees if you're a writer because
these are brilliant people who who
penetrate to the heart and figure out
and in fact one of the people Ryan at
the end of the write down there was who
found a basically a brilliant argument
that his approach couldn't work although
he him so the Ilyich artist still
doesn't accept that but so it was
remarkable in the sense that it really
ignited the
community for people who because it's a
very exciting approach it didn't work
but it's a very exciting approach so
really ignited the community to look at
it carefully I think you know it would
actually be difficult for someone who's
not well known in the field and does
have a proof to get it accepted by the
community and I was discussing this with
a friend who's an editor in chief of a
major journal and gets on a daily basis
proofs that P equals NP and proofs that
P naught equals NP and and there's no
way you can read them all and sort
through them all and they don't get
refereed and I just said you know if it
happened that someone who wasn't
extremely well known and had a lot of
credibility came up with the proof it
would be a very difficult process for
them to get that proof read to get it
accepted because it would probably first
of all be very long and complicated too
so there's sort of a social process in
the mathematical community to get it
proof accepted and it would be difficult
to to go through that if you weren't if
you didn't already have some credibility
so over the might several dozen claims
there into I'm not sure there any
remarkable ones that's the thing they're
all the same the there are proofs at P
equals NP and those are inevitably some
long messy algorithm with a statement
like well I ran it on a clique problem
with 300 nodes on my in turbo Pascal and
it only took 14 seconds okay what are
gonna do with that so I always respond
to those people look if you can really
prove P equal NP you can take your
algorithm and factor big numbers and
there are some famous ones out there on
line factor one of those numbers and
then come talk to me okay so it's a easy
test then there because I mean reading
those algorithms forget it I mean those
are always very complicated then there
were the proofs that P different from NP
and with the exception of the de la
lokar's
argument which has at least the ring of
plausibility the other ones always look
the same if you scan them they always
look the same
they always have somewhere in there they
a statement that well you know long
preamble blah blah blah blah blah but
somewhere in there they say well clearly
an algorithm for solving click or
satisfiability or any one of the other
hard problems save click the an
algorithm for solving click has to
operate the following way clearly and
then they have a long analysis why
that's going to take you know
exponential time but that's the whole
point is the clearly you know because
the algorithms can operate in some
devious way and there may be things that
are not that couldn't can that you don't
understand that could could be the
algorithm and so you know you just have
to find that clearly and then then then
you can knock it down any way that it
has been my experience with you know
several cases there are there have been
a couple of proofs of people attempt to
prove P goes in P which led to barriers
to proofs of barriers so you know
basically some people had come up with
algorithms for the Traveling says no
problem and they didn't work people
found other examples and then they came
up with more complicated algorithms and
this proved these forced researchers
like McCarthy and akagi's at Bell Labs
to come up with proof that listen no
matter you know this approach will never
to prove barriers okay be I think a
proof that forces researchers to prove
but prove an interesting theorem like
like gonococcus lower bound is a
remarkable I should also you know back
in the late 70s my buddy at I was done
at Harvard Harry Lewis and I wrote a
scientific American article about this
question P versus NP and we posed a few
np-complete problems and and this was
perhaps and we received in response
probably many dozens of what would be
very early attempts of P equals NP okay
you know people you know who were some
kids some some old ladies who wrote us
who wrote you know I think that I can
solve the graphic ordinary problem and
here is an algorithm so we decided to
read them all and find a counterexample
basically we had you know we ran a
contest okay so you know we decided the
most remarkable attempt will be the one
that required the largest counter
example and unfortunately Buddhism did
not work very well because the winner
was a man who said if the graph has
fewer than 15 nodes do it exhaustively
you know and otherwise and then of
course he stumbled ok you remark that
there's a page on the web I think it's
called the P versus NP page but I'm not
sure where it has a very very long list
of attempts at solving P versus NP so
has the name of the person and a few
remarks about what the approach is so if
you google the P versus NP page I
something like that you'll find this
long list of attempted solutions further
so there's a historically notable proof
that P not equal NP from the I think
early 70s in the Soviet Union
what so maybe Ryan knows it better ok
anyway so the a person who sort of posed
the P versus NP problem an equivalent
problem in Russia unfortunately went on
to write down a fallacious proof that P
was different essentially the P was
different from n P the language was
slightly different and because of this
fallacious proof which was accepted
because this person was politically
influential it almost killed complexity
theory in the Soviet Union in fact it
pretty much did kill complexity theory
in the Soviet Union the people who
managed to like Leonid Levin who managed
to do complexity theory in the Soviet
Union
did it by emigrating so that was
probably the most historically important
proof that P not equal NP okay yeah yeah
I'd like to thank the audience for for
your attention and for the wonderful
questions that you've raised and also to
thank the panelists for their
interesting remark